et est ce que il ya aussi harry potter
qui est très présent dans votre vie
et celle que vous avez un un tatouage du
du professeur en sueur montrez-moi à
ceux qui sont montrable j'entends par là
alors vous allez ouvrir le tatouage de
harry potter quand même dans des
endroits
très intime ce serait un peu c'est un
peu inquiétant
voilà
mouiller un peu pour qui
ah le voilà le fameux professeur et
sorcier dumbledore et bien entendu ah
oui donc vous êtes vraiment bas fidèles
à ce rendez vous c'est vraiment une
partie de vous aussi un vrai un vrai fan
je sais des films qui m'ont qui m'ont
tellement appris qui m'habite qui me
vous savez je les ai revu la semaine
dernière peut tous mais je les regarde
sur une base régulière sans jamais
vraiment m'en lasse et je les connais
par coeur je connais les dialogues part
car en anglais en français